i ragazzi pervenute verso la vittoria di
ieri erano rimasti che sta succedendo un
casino e vi lascio al video news ha
chiuso quello sentito gente ci siete
esplode come fa riesplodere che vale
chiaro ma smettila
cercate qualcosa
prendi le bombe
cosa vogliono fare
madonna che una porta in titanio alle
ragazzine di trento loro creazione di
borse parlare amici dobbiamo parlarne di
voi deve uscire aspettavi sta facendo
seguire allora parla tutto esci tu ok
già bio è scommetti lucchetti alle ceste
assolutamente sconosciuto ragazzi perché
io non ho più niente però va beh eccomi
mia risposato qua adesso escono i capi e
ci adesso sono dentro immagine contagia
come facciamo
ci vogliono togliere che possiamo fare
finte perché sono dentro la terra
nicolaci di cofito scapperei a sto punto
quindi signori ci hanno assaltato la
base è abbastanza berlusca pescara in
quello per la roba più utile perché ci
stancheremo in un altro pochissimo ma
chi torna poi torneremo quando le acque
si sentano torniamo a noi mettiamo tutta
forza che fanno tramite ha fatto cosa mi
hanno fatto fuori coltellate e poi sono
risposato ma andrebbe fatto fuori erano
già entrati commentiamo non fa ma io io
volevo costruire poi un altro muro
dentro per
però il problema è che poi si è pagato
tutto ci hanno marcato niente se stavo
mettendo le ore all importante che la
roba importante addosso però un sacco di
armi l'acqua possiamo andare avanti a
mandare a casa di marcia a prenderle
robben e mentre solo quattro immagini
non so dove non abbiamo ricordo io mi
ricordo io mi ricorda la query ti
riconosci si carica è ok
mamma mia niente perché so sfornato
praticamente zero se anno se c'è un buco
guardagli entro gli può così roma come
ha fatto entrare io ero morte per aborto
e presenta di c4 non fatto se si
consegua non ci potra poi anche spaccare
il petto di un piccone chi nonché con e
prenditi da un piccone spada i vestini
basta perché non è vero meglio la cisco
entrare no hanno fatto le foto mai
aperto sono dei babbi agli attacchi a
sedi di male o peccato la trappola mi
sono fatto male ma a posto non mi ha
fatto così tanto ma la prima ma c'è
tutto gli ruba tutto ma fammi stare mai
costruito vostro pazzi ma come ha fatto
anche paramount e lo bacia
beh vabbè ci riprendiamo e ci
riprendiamo le cose ma mamma proprio
ogni malato di mente sono di babri e 124
pistola sensi prendi tutto prendi subito
si fa ma la pistola ad acqua questa cosa
o aprendogli tolto la rottura
l'autorizzazione alla base veramente io
tolgo tutto spacca qualsiasi cosa una
motosega serve prediche no io gli lascio
un teschio nella una roccia nel box ma
non si può
gli abbiamo dimenticano update mario
gliel'ha lasciato tre lettere vabbè
adesso vedete voi adesso però non c'è
niente bene abbiamo più roba di contone
avevamo prima
perché loro vari noi quindi io andai via
che ci ha veramente paura
gli ho scritto nabi nel male la sua cosa
nessuno che devono rimanere sempre un in
base al meno chiudetela almeno chiude
mamma fosse stata chiusa non avere nulla
che non cambiano mai
goro sacconi ci rifacciamo la ma che
dire neanche di parlare a sto punto una
base proprio perché perché forti una
base grande se dopo tre bombe ci sono
ignorate ma ricordo che a farti fare
quando c'è un modo per fortificare
comunque si erano uniti era impossibile
fare meglio di così
non contento che abbiamo avuto già che
non in sé è andata meglio del previsto
visto che hanno lasciato la passione ma
è normale se io direi dai partiamo da
qui facciamo velocemente guardato senza
troppi complimenti con la legna
facciamoci una roba da una torre di
pietra anche volendo bravissimo preso a
ma possiamo potenziare con la roccia poi
direi una cosa proprio molto più piccola
vede così si certo non ci sono perché
ogni rumore ragazzi si riparte
rinasceremo dalle ceneri e partiremo una
stalla ancora più grande anche quella
non mi piace che la faceva schifo ma
ragazzi veramente è stato semplice di
costruire materiali la porta aperta e
facile più forti di prima ragazzi più
forti di prima
beh sì forti prima un attimino gendre
piano per aicon con tutti i loro
materiali diciamo abbiamo recuperato
bellissimo buy
sono contento almeno avuto la vendita
era proprio il caro l'istante caro e non
è male per averla di fatta così al volo
direi che no no no no ci sta ci sta ci
sta un botto io sono solo contento che
abbiamo tutti fucile si no quale loro
cosa mi ha dato importanti non quella
guerra che eravamo messi meglio di loro
con i fucili certo voglia e la caviamo
in sei che doveva fare niente sono
realizzati o comunque dai la base
mi sembra che già un attimino come
aprire che siamo messi abbastanza bene
siamo messi bene rifatto le ceste diamo
luogo superiore per ora un po in pietra
ancora un po in legno purtroppo i
materiali sono ancora quelli che sono ma
tranquilli siamo molto veloci e rifarci
e avremo la nostra vendetta
avevano anche il vino su per fare i
proiettili quindi nei prossimi episodi
vedrete a eppure la motosega fabiano che
bella carica per che bella questa
motosega mar
sono proprio contento meno chiudere o
almeno quello cioè di ok va bene
proseguito dio ci alleiamo con mike sono
sicuro che non potrà rifiutare mai che
se guardi questi video mike hai visto la
nostra pro da ginelli possiamo allearci
con i cavalieri della valle per i
ragazzi abbiamo costruito la base nuova
che è ovviamente temporanea visto quello
che è successo però almeno abbiamo
recuperato tutti diciamo che abbiamo
perso i materiali principali cioè tipo
das pietra
lei però abbiamo guadagnato un sacco di
roba extract tipo pistole robe alle armi
l'abbiamo ancora tutte legno siamo messi
anche abbastanza bene rotta solo perché
ha lasciato la porta aperta ragazzi
chiudete la porta è necessario e poi
proseguito
oggi al segna mento sì perché non è
possibile poi ci alleeremo con mike devo
fare la stessa cosa che loro in sei
hanno fatto a noi due male però ragazzi
ci vediamo un po stupito e bacino tutti
fateci sapere cosa ne pensate nei
commenti del team capi progetto livelli
[Musica]
ma